je comprends ascarat que vous regrettiez
d'abord déballer votre vie intime
merci alors marc antoine vous le savez
bien nous donner régulièrement des
nouvelles des stars du paf est
d'ailleurs j'aimerais savoir comment
comment marielle dombasle bonjour
valérie alors je suis ravi d'être dans
votre émission
alors voulez-vous dire valérie que j'ai
un faible pour les séducteurs à la
chemise ouverte aux cheveux mi-longs et
dont on ne comprend rien à ce qu'il
raconte donc chapin vous allez nick
evans ban attend donc avec impatience à
me présenter jean michel maire
et ce n'est pas mort et de silence ça
pousse vous étiez avec nous et vous est
revenu sur le plateau touche pas mon
jour et stéphane marie ne s'élancera à
valérie voulez-vous dire vraiment que
j'adore sophie favier 1
pourquoi parce que cela plus belle des
plantes sa chemise jaune on dirait un
bouton d'or au bout diagana plus d'un
qui aimeraient la rosée olalalala là
j'ai fait du corps des leones à jean
claude van damme comment vous allez ok
c'est jean claude van damme bonjour au
revoir c'est bientôt l'automne un
pouvoir skier c'est super ok j'ai vu que
vous êtes un peu embrouillé avec laurent
ruquier c'est pas bien
ok pourquoi parce que j'aime la v1 la
violence verbale c'est pas bien donc
valérie tu vas voir laurent oui tout le
regarde dans les yeux comme çà et là un
couple est retourné coup de pied dans
machete poker c'est important y'a un
oiseau
plus plus calme et un peu un thème la
violence ça va glisser moon valérie
bègue ali moi je voudrais vous dire que
j'aime beaucoup cette solution parce que
il ya de l'amour de la joie de vivre tu
attends un surtout il y là des plombes à
forte poitrine bras soir et l'autre des
gosses ou libres n'ont vraiment pas
orientée vers quelqu'un qui arbore moins
de patrick 20e chevelure sa crêpe
bonsoir que ça
alors alors là je suis extrêmement
perturbé parce que j'ai l'impression de
voir double j'ai l'impression de voir 2
jean luc lemoine
oui j'ai emballé rit pas de questions en
4/3 et pourquoi simplement parce que
hier quand j'étais en train de bosser
dessus il avait le mans il bosse est
venu me raconter une anecdote
et quand elle a terminé là on était
aujourd'hui